this guy has tearing off the National
Football League record book for a New
Orleans Saints team that is atop the NFC
South through 11 weeks he is none other
than Michael Thomas how are you sir hey
how you doing rich spent a chat I
appreciate you joining me here Michael
Thomas what makes you the receiver that
you are you know just never get into I
never get into low on just controlling
without control and you know staying
consistent as possible never going
against my routine or never changing
things that have gotten me here well I
mean then I guess what drives you what
motivates my teammates I feel like my
teammates count on me
this organization they count on me they
expect me to make big plays and they
need me to make big place to reach their
goal so ultimately on this plan for that
the guys are out and we have one common
goal and that that's that's the one
that's where all my efforts are going to
well I mean Michael you're a wide
receiver you're supposed to be a diva
you're not supposed to be talking this
way I mean let's be honest here you know
so yeah yeah you know it's very to be a
guy that's win a lot of games that the
feeling of winning is waived better than
being known as a diva and I'm more I get
more excited and more joy from winning
so once I fell in love with winning
that's just always what I'm trying to do
have you ever demanded the football of
Drew Brees or from Drew Brees is that
conversation ever happened from Michael
Thomas to Drew Brees in the first four
years of your career never even makes
tremendous decisions he is who he is
from making the right decisions every
time I get an opportunity to be on the
end of one of his targets I just want to
complete it and complete the play for
him and ultimately I just I don't know I
just take a lot of responsibility for my
dog well in terms of that you know if
you're in the right spot Brees is gonna
go to you if you're in the right spot
and the play calls for it you're in the
right spot you know it's coming your way
essentially right Fisher okay so what is
your relationship like with Sean Peyton
what does he say to you Michael he's a
master motivator he comes from the
Parcells motivational tree I wonder what
your relationship is like what the Super
Bowl winning head coach of the Saints
it's tremendous I love want to work
every day to play for Sean paid he's a
great leader he sets its own early on at
the beginning of the week with our
preparation he emphasizes how important
preparation is and if you look at Drew
Brees and how he prepares it goes hand
in hand so it's a lot of transparency
disclosed in a lot of reasons why these
guys are oh they are and one of they've
had success and they're great leaders
and they lead by example
Sean you can't play the game but he's
he's he's trying to put the perfect play
for us to to win the game or to you know
get points or just to be successful so
you have to appreciate that and it makes
life easier just going going to work
with a motivated coach went a lot of
swagger and it was really aggressive
Toulon has a lot of emotions well I mean
is he keeping track of all the records
that you're set in breaking or on pace
to break Michael no solely just playing
football okay does the name Jerry Rice
ever pop in your head I mean seriously
obviously you got a ton of more time to
go but you are situating yourself for a
long run here that you've already
started statistically Michael I wonder
if that actually ever goes through your
temples not really I'm still young and I
feel like when you're winning games and
you're having success as an overall unit
and your team's win in those type of
things people start to notice and pay
attention to more so as long as we keep
winning and staying on track and focus
on things you need to focus on I feel
like the rewards and the conversations
and people will catch up you know
eventually and that's always how my
story's been so I've never I never
really tried to compare myself to other
people I just always try to play my game
to the best of my ability at a high
level and see where it takes me so who's
your Josh Bart as far as Jerry Rice out
of the receiver yes he is
he's one of the greatest visions of all
time I like him I like your I like Randy
Moss I like drilling so between those
three those guys are exciting you can
learn a lot from them but one thing
about Jerry he was very consistent he
set the bar real high he led by example
from all the stories I heard of his work
ethic and how he prepared guys that have
been around them coaches that I've had
that play with them that I maybe
actually got to coach with them they do
bring them up office just about our
preparation our work ethic but I feel
like that we you know selfish or not
selfish but wrong to me to to kind of
compare myself to another person no I
know that's why I brought it up you know
what I mean like I'm not I'm not sitting
here thinking you know what I'm you're
you're now and you're for saying you're
gonna run down Jerry Rice I mean I'm not
suggesting of course you know what I
mean and and I don't know if you're
aware Michael Thomas but I do have some
insight on on your regimen your workout
regimen and your desire to be great are
you aware of that Michael well I mean
you might not be able to tell seeing me
on the Rich Eisen show or on NFL Network
cuz I wear these bulky sweaters and
suits but you and I see us a same
trainer Michael are you wear that Peter
Park here in Los Angeles
I see him oh yeah yeah okay that's right
and he's a tremendous guy he tells you
you know he tells me Michael that you
are always focused on being the greatest
you possibly can be he has told me this
you know when when we started chatting
about the NFL a little bit and that is
what I've been told that you are always
never wavering on trying to be the
greatest you possibly can be and I'm
wondering if you would agree with that
most definitely I try to stay in the
moment and make the most out of my
opportunity early on I didn't do much
media like after I might do it do like I
think we were supposed to go on this
show maybe like week for a week five
when the team was doing a little bit
some adversity and guys were injured and
stuff like that and Mauro's woman goes
to play for a chance
Bishop and I valued to my team so I
didn't really want to get distracted
with the contract I signed there how
many passes out sketching the only thing
I want to do is win game so it's
minigames we need to win and get him
back to where we left off last year and
correcting our mistakes that's just the
ultimate goal well you know Michael I
appreciate that you take that attitude
but just know this appearing on the Rich
Eisen show always makes your team better
I don't know if you're aware of that but
it always does okay no no I just want
you to be aware of that that that this
show always improves the person who's on
it and I'm I take full credit there is
an iron-rich and Eisen is basically what
I'm telling you right here yeah
absolutely that's cam Jordan we came up
but the reason why I did want to have
you on then is because obviously what
was going on with Drew Brees and Teddy
Bridgewater walked me through what
Bridgewater did and what he meant and
means to this team Michael Thomas he
said let me get his job we wouldn't we
wouldn't have wanted to have to have
anyone else in that situation it gave us
opportunity to you know allow drew to
get healthy but also bring Teddy along
and play for one another we had some
tough games some tough opponents we knew
at the schedule what it was you know a
little while ago we had a playoff teams
but we had a lemonade all the noise and
basically in control we control and lock
in and play for one another and I feel
like Teddy's the ultimate leader also he
he cares about his teammates he's very
mature
he's vocal he knows when to be vocal um
it's just some really good cool things
about him that makes you other types or
element and want to see him be
successful so we have a great team I
feel like and we just want we just want
to see everyone be successful ok before
I let you go what's gonna happen the
Saturday after Thanksgiving Michael what
do you think's going to happen on that
day in in the world of college football
Ohio State will be the number one team
in college mm-hmm football and then LSU
number two and then number three or four
I guess I'll find out mm-hmm you don't
think a certain institution of higher
learning up north if you will has a team
that can actually make some hay this
time around if you've watched I don't
even think they think they're in the way
we went then like that day analytics
then you know like a judge there and
check the track record the past five six
years I don't know what you would date
off of maybe they have some new form of
culture going on up there we'll find out
but I know that Ryan day was bucking off
play around coach Mickey variety was set
the tone and a lot of guys that I played
you know a lot of the older guys that I
played in that game before definitely
elite the younger guys know I know that
and I you know I'm I will fully admit
that I was I was hoping that the school
would try and suss out what ever
happened with chase young for another
couple weeks so I was hoping that that
would take us to December I fully admit
that but you know anything can happen on
any given Saturday Michael you know Sam
do you think you're happy yeah yeah but
you know this is Buckeyes team up north
just detect the last five games you want
no I'm you know I'm aware of that but
you won't even say the school you won't
even say the school the team up north
will you say that we say the M word
you won't even say that all right
Michael
look I'll just defer to you you're
balling out I could not be more pleased
that you you'd come on the show yeah I'm
always asking for you you know that cuz
I just really enjoy the way you go about
your business who you are and what
you've been able to accomplish so far
it's just been dynamite and I only want
the ultimate amount of success for you I
appreciate that thank you and I enjoyed
coming on your show and thank you I'll
definitely come back around just around
the playoff time out somewhere to talk
and you know we're following you at
can't guard Mike I think you're out
there on our Instagram every now and
then so we noticed yeah we see the likes
we see it we see it also greatly
appreciate that yes I appreciate your
support
right back at you that's Michael Thomas
there is nobody in the National Football
League with more catches or receiving
yards at this point this season and he
has been off to a remarkable start to
his NFL career right here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app